representative wall
all set to go awesome okay sir
thank you um for the committee members i
have to read a script
uh that all committees are all zoom
meetings are going by so i need to read
this first so sit back and relax a
minute
good afternoon everyone thank you for
zooming in for this meeting as chair of
the house legislative
administration committee i find that due
to the state of the
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of covert 19 pandec
in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this was a full committee work session
on bills referred to the house
legislative administration committee
it will be followed by an executive
session
please note that there are no physical
work is no
physical location to observe and listen
contemporaneously
to this meeting which was authorized
pursuant to the governor's emergency
order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming that we are
a providing public access to the meeting
by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video or other electronic means
we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through this
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by clicking on the
following website address
do you want me to read that whole
address should
https colon slash
slash www dot
zoom dot u s slash small
j nine eight eight four two
nine four
or dialing one of the following phone
numbers
1-929-205-6099
or 130
b providing public notice of the
necessary information for accessing the
meeting
we previously gave notice to the meeting
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar
c providing a mechanism for the public
to alert the public
body during the meeting if there are
problems with access
if anybody has a problem please call
271 3600 or email at capital h
c f l e g dot state dot
nh dot u s d adjourning the meeting
if the public is unable to accept access
the meeting
in the event of the public being unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff who are on
the meeting
on the meeting excuse me assisting us we
have pam smiling
as the meeting host thank you pam we
have
staff providing support jim four
and brad greenroom thank you both for
being here this was a work session on
three bills referred to the legislative
administration
for interim study an executive session
will follow
copies of the interim study bills have
been posted on the main page of the
general court website
under the heading remote meetings
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states his or her
presence please
also state whether there is anyone in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
the clerk will not take the attendance
at the roll call thank you
you want me to take the roll call now
yes please okay i know you're there
representative lee mr president
frost nothing wrong
wait we need to um have people unmute
themselves and
explain that they're here and where they
are and if anybody is in the room
okay thank you
uh smith we didn't get um frost
nothing more wait wait wait let let
frost speak
ready okay bro okay i i am present
and i am currently alone although i am
in my kitchen and that may change
good for you nothing wrong
i'm here and no one's in the room with
me thank you
turcotte not here
willam i'm here nobody's in the room
with me
thank you hinge not here
i'm here and i'm alone graham here and i
am alone
okay hill not present
right i'm here and i it's just the dog
the kids just left
well i'm watching green
i'm here and i'm alone thank you
that's it on youtube
okay folks um i believe that i know that
pam smiling has sent you
all copies of the bills uh house bill
relative to the disclosure of the
sources of legislative bill proposals
and the disclosure of certain
information by lobbyists
the second bill we have is house bill
relative to employment as a lobbyist and
the third and final bill we have
is hb 1669 requiring electronic
filing of lobbyist forms and statements
we will discuss all these bills and then
we will go into an exec session
and vote on all three on 441 does anyone
have anything they want to discuss
second call 441 any discussion
uh representative lay would like to
speak
madam chair
yes may i speak
no one has anything to discuss on
forward 41. no
matter the chair chair uh i'm douglas
representative lay is raising his hand
go ahead representative
thank you madam chair yeah um you know i
think there's merit to the
uh ideas here i think the bill as
currently written
would have issues i i think we talked
about that in the
in the hearing we did have on it um but
i do think there's merit and
um i think the idea is not a bad one um
particularly on identifying
uh or disclosing the source of certain
legislation there are some
quirks and how that would have to be
done uh particularly if it comes from
multiple sources things like that
i also noted that in the past there was
a proposal to maybe put something into
house rules
um and that may be an alternative
pathway so uh
you know i i i actually see some merit
to this as for the uh
uh the disclosure of certain information
i think that one
that was a difficult part of this bill
if i recall
um that was the bit about the phone
calling and things like that so
i'm not so sure about that but certainly
on the disclosure
uh of looking towards maybe crafting
something to permit disclosure of
uh sources of model legislation maybe
with the permission of
the prime sponsor something like that
that might be okay
so that's my two cents i agree with you
on that um
i i have the background of the history
on this bill
the bill has been presented twice before
and has been found inexpedient to
legislate both times before based on the
fact that
it might be better it's a good idea
and at the same time it might be better
to deal with it in terms of house rules
and that's why it's been killed before
uh
actually with house rules as you all
know we we vote
on our rules at the beginning of each
two-year session
and we're never going to have something
go through all the hearings and all the
processes and all it might be
beneficial to have this go through rules
but i
i would go along with what the committee
wants anyone else
i just the technical thing
representative rice has having a
an issue her screen froze she had a log
off and she's coming back down
momentarily oh
okay
and uh representative graham has his
hand up oh did he
see it thank you madam chairman aye
representative graham go ahead right um
i agree with the fact that it should be
in rules if we are going to go
forward with this that way um our
membership gets to pick and choose
every two years on how to modify
this rather than trying to take it
through legislation
which as we all know is so easy to
change
once we put in the statute
sarcasm for anybody listening
i'm listening okay
doug do you see anyone else from here uh
i do not i haven't spoke representative
wilhelm has his hand up
can i just ask as we move to executive
session
this is just a question about process
do we make a recommendation uh
how did how did how does it how does it
work i know how to vote
vote a bill up or down but it's unclear
i should have said something in the very
beginning we have two options
we can recommend for further legislation
or
we can not recommend for future
legislation
and either way my personal opinion is
it doesn't truly make a huge difference
because
we can't bind a future legislature
and anyone who wants can file any one of
these bills
for the next session but we need to go
through this process
because because it's the process we have
so we will need a recommend we will need
a motion either to recommend or not
recommend for future legislation when we
move into our exact session
i know it sounds a little confusing and
then uh madam chair may i ask a question
as well
excuse me madam chair may i ask a
question as well this is representative
yeah thank you thank you uh and this is
really just for anybody who hasn't gone
through the process before so
there are also uh there's a committee
report or whatever on this
i mean it's uh you know what you will be
a committee statement yeah
yes yeah okay and so any sort of
explanation
uh could be contained therein okay very
good thank you
exactly and this won't be taken up on
the floor of the house what we're doing
is forwarding our
it won't be the blurb it won't be the
committee report this time they're
calling it the committee statement
so we will make a statement now if we
make a statement
uh recommending future legislation that
may strengthen an issue
or it may not if we
make a recommendation not recommend or
make a motion rather
not recommending future legislation and
once again
anyone can file a bill if they want to
so it kind of puts people in a hard
place at times i think but
just think about whether or not you
think this is the way we should go
should we on this particular bill
recommend
for future legislation or should we
allow the rules committee to take over
and us vote on it when the time comes i
think that's what it's going to boil
down to
uh representative rice has her hands up
thank you sorry about that i got booted
um so if i missed something please bear
with me but i think that if this can go
to rules that that's
where we should let it go i don't think
putting it in stat
you really ties our hands and limits
things so i
i would like to see us just recommend
you know no further legislation let's
bring it in front of rules
okay representative wilhelm did you have
your hand up again
no oh okay i'm sorry
anyone else i see
no one with a hand up
no or not are you caught going once
going twice
i'm sorry so shall i auction it off
going once going twice
okay if you're comfortable with where
you think you're going with this
hold on to your motion please we'll move
on to house bill 1359
relative to employment as a lobbyist tim
smith put this in
and the biggest question on the bill was
how much time we should allow between an
individual
being a legislator and becoming a
lobbyist and according to research that
we got from pam smarling on 38 states
have some type of uh law regarding this
and they vary from the length of
say you leave your um seat mid-term or
something
if the midterm would be one year
you'd have to wait a year before you
came became a lobbyist or say you
finished your term
you'd still have to wait then two years
before coming along becoming
a lobbyist so and some states have it
for as much as two years or longer
so the question is how long in new
hampshire
i will tell you that on election day i
was standing with a former legislator
from up
um i would call it the north country who
came down to support
a particular candidate and i asked her
when she became a lobbyist and she moved
straight from being a
legislator to being a lobbyist i talked
with someone else
who waited two years so it does vary
right within our own state
we are all volunteers and
i would not feel comfortable personally
having to wait as long as something like
four years
because anyone can get a paying job i
hope within four years and not have to
wait
for the job of their dreams to be a
lobbyist
so the question is how long should
anyone wait
so i think that they'll have some merit
um i'd like to hear from others
representative rice has her hand up
thank you very much
um so i'm very uncomfortable with
telling people they can't take a job as
you stated we are volunteer legislators
we make a hundred dollars a year
and i don't know about you guys but i
spend a lot of time doing this
i'm not making a killing if a job
opportunity came to me i would want to
have that make that decision on my own
not have the legislature
a statute make that for me um
so i i can't support this going forward
and
and because i i'm just not comfortable
with telling anyone you can't take a job
if the opportunity presents itself
okay anyone else
come on right here representative
and green both have their hands up
go ahead representative green go ahead
go ahead okay
yes uh i'm concerned about the bill too
i mean all right
we've discussed this all in the past
just
there's just some vagueness about this
about
discussing negotiating playing with the
lobby as a lobbyist client say
i i'll be the legislature i want to go
back to my old employer
bae systems now uh that be
uh they have a pack you know
i and even though if i'm not a member i
mean
how there's a lot of details are left
out of this bill as what like
this a lobbyist or lobbyist client
i guess that's what i'm feeling with
this
who else had the hand up pam
representative graham
ah representative graham representative
graham's ready uh madam chair
thank you madam chair i i agree with
um representative rice and
representative greene that
we probably should not support
recommendation for further legislation
as you mentioned madam chair there are
38 states
that have some kind of law on this but
i'm willing to bet you my hundred
dollars for this year
that they do not make as little as we do
um for all the time that they put in
i know in mass it's in the tens of
thousands i won't say how much
but um i think that
it is something that we should not put
into legislation
it it really is a fact that we come out
of a volunteer legislator
um and then if i'm offered a job maybe i
want to take it probably i don't
but especially the way this one is
currently done i have to wait
36 years to
before i could take the job i don't
think i'll
be doing it at that point but i don't
think i'm going to go forward on this
okay i hope you're around 36 years from
now
i will say that in research from tam
smarling
the executive branch and classified
employees
do have to wait for six months the
bill's come before
the house a couple of other times and it
has been killed
both of those times
so i'm just putting that out there from
research that we have
is anyone else represent representative
frost and then representative wilhelm
um thank you i'd like to clarify that
the bill
says that you are um would be
restricted from accepting a position for
a period of time equal to twice the
total length of their current term in
office
which means four years not 36.
that's a good point yeah and i think
that goes back to what i said if you
leave midterm you only have to wait
another year
if you leave after the end of year two
years you have to wait two years
that's correct okay
oh no no no i take that bet twice the
total length of your current term
so if you spend two years you have to
wait four years
right yeah right
representative wilhelm has this hand up
thank you
so just to clarify when it comes to
recommending legislation
for the future or not it's
you know if there are details in it that
were we think needs to be
refined further uh is there an
opportunity to clarify that or it's just
simply
you know this bill should be considered
moving forward or not
um doug help me with this one please i
believe
that you can that we're doing it based
on the concept and we can have the
wording
the way we would want it is that correct
just means future legislation it doesn't
mean it has to be the identical bill
does it well i i mean obviously any
madam chair may i speak it doesn't have
to be
you know we're not rec we don't have to
be necessarily recommending the specific
legislation i mean
there can be the report
or statement can say you know that um
the idea of uh of of a cooling period or
whatever of for becoming a lobbyist may
have some merit
but perhaps not as long a period as is
recommended here
and there were also concerns about the
um
the language about taking a job um that
the sort of bae systems thing that i
remember we did discuss
um that that would be somewhat
problematic but um
you know you could uh sort of state in
the committee statement that
there is some merit here perhaps not in
the exact language or the exact proposal
here
um so i think that that's how you could
do it representative wilhelm
that's that's what i was thinking um and
um but again that doesn't bind anybody
going forward
they can submit any way they want that's
how i'm looking at it also there's
another
second provision in this bill it says
prohibition on employment offers from
the lobbyists
no member of the general court may
negotiate an employment offer
with a lobbyist a lobbyist client or the
parent or subsidiary of the lobbyists
client while the members serving in
office
even if such employment would not begin
until after the member's term of office
has ended
yeah that was that was um representative
greene's point
er earlier um that the case yeah you
going back to work
representative frost has her hand up
yeah um thank you so what i'm seeing in
this bill
is that the employment would be
prohibited if it would require
registration as
a lobbyist so you could still go back to
your job
even if they had a lobbying arm or a
pac but if your employment would require
your registering as a lobbyist under rsa
1 then that would be prohibited behavior
i don't i honestly don't see a problem
with that i don't think this is keeping
anybody from
getting a paying job i think this is
getting forbidding people from taking a
paying job
that results from their term in
office that would require their being
registered as a lobbyist it's that
that um ethical gray area that we're
looking to clear up here
if i'm a madam chair i'm sorry yes
representative
um but what i see here is it states
right here an employment offer with a
lobbyist a lobbyist
client and to me that would that sounds
like
um you know what representative greene
was stating about
his work at bae or the parent or subsidy
of a lobbyist client i mean i just
what i envision is all these branches
going off and you can't have anything to
do with
what's at the end of these branches so
be sure to really do your homework
because maybe you can't go to work there
that's how i'm interpreting it where
you know for me it just
i i yeah do you know did i make any
sense at all
yes to me you did um
am i am correct in thinking that city
lobbyist is working for the hospital
association you can't then work for the
hospital association
even if you step out not being a
lobbyist but you can't even work for the
hospital association
i mean that's the way you can't
negotiate employment with the lobbyist
or the lobbyist client
representative graham has his hand up as
well go ahead
and to follow along with that madam
chair
um any hospital that was part of the
hospital association you could not
negotiate with
if you take it to that logical
conclusion
um but if we're not going to
beat this much longer i think that we
can move on i think we've all made up
our mind on how we're going to vote on
this
and on all three of them at this point i
would assume
okay the voice of wisdom is everyone
comfortable moving on to 1669.
and could i just interject a little bit
madam chairman
um go ahead to remind people that if
you're looking for the raise your hand
button and you're not
seeing it if you if you click on the
participant
label at the bottom of your screen you
should
be able to find that button
very very important thank you i just uh
thank you
yeah thank you okay we will move on to
house bill 1669.
requiring electronic filing of lobbyist
forms and statements
the analysis says this bill requires
that
one year after implementation of an
electronic filing system
by the secretary of state the
registration forms and fee
and expense reports of lobbyists shall
be filed electronically with the
secretary of state
and made available as public records on
on the department of
state's internet site we had testimony
i believe that said the secretary of
state's
office is in the process of
getting these forms developed and i
don't know what the status of that is
does anybody know
representative graham has his hand up
representative clarence
i don't know the status but i remember
the deputy secretary saying it was
supposed to be done this year
but i'd be willing to bet that with all
the disruptions we've had
that it's going to be delayed but he
also didn't have any objections to
to doing this the only question again
that raises its head
is it better for the secretary of state
to do it in administrative rules or is
it better for us to put it into
legislation
and that's the real question that we we
have to decide
when we decide whether to recommend to
go forward
with this topic as legislation and to be
put into the rsas or not
fully agree um does anyone else have
comments to make on 1669.
as representatives lay would say going
once
going twice have we completed our
discussion
on house bill 1669.
there's objection to that idea i guess
so
okay uh we will now move into our exact
session
so we will take these bills in the order
in which we have discussed them
do we have a motion on house bill 441
and again the motions can be either that
we do recommend for future legislation
or we do not recommend for future
legislation
i don't know who came first
representative graham or representative
wilhelm i didn't see
what's that go ahead representative
wilhelm uh thank you
can we recommend it to go to rules
um well in our statement that we make
if we for example if we say we do not
recommend for future legislation
in the statement that is made our
so-called blurb or
committee report now called statement we
can say
that the committee believes that
this issue is better addressed through
rules
there's nothing wrong with that
representative graham has his handle uh
thank you madam chair i would move that
we not recommend this for further
legislation i would like to be able to
talk to that
okay did i hear you correctly to say you
recommend future legislation
not to not
okay do we have a second represent
representative rice has indicated a
second
a second okay who made the motion again
represent graham thank you and
representative rice second is it
yeah i get that first one i missed
thanks
okay um madame quirk are you ready
okay representative graham why don't you
speak to your motion please
thank you very much madam chair um i
personally like
our former colleague gary richardson's
uh blurb from the prior where he talks
about the merit for
this bill um that was heard before
and that it be referred to rules and
that is
if this passes the way that i will
structure
the um
a statement that's the that's the term
i'm looking for
for this and i'll have it for you by the
16th if this passes
okay representative rice do you have
anything to add to that
is there any further discussion uh i can
may i speak madam chair
yes representative lay thank you yeah i
i i
if we can put into the report that uh or
into the statement
um that this might be better suited to
be considered as part of rules
um then i could support this uh the the
motion here
uh to go ahead and do that um to
recommend against future legislation but
basically
um make the argument that it it's better
suited really in rules
um and figure it out from there so
and again representative graham has his
hand up
go ahead representative graham ah thank
you madam chair
um the other reason i would say that is
because
the house can have its own rules if we
put legislation in
who knows what the senate will do but at
least if we can get it into rules
um the house would have a position on
bills that
that originated in the house at least
and i i would add that if it were made a
law
it would take a lot longer to amend it
than it would if it were a rule
yes we address rules every two years
madam chair may ask you yeah yeah i
i mean just to build up what
representative graham is saying i mean i
also suspect that
in any such legislation it's quite
likely the senate would not
go along with it so uh maybe we try
to see about putting it into rules in
the house and we gain some experience
from it and see whether it sort of
yields the results that
um the sponsors i think would like to
see from it um
and then we would have we if it did
yield the sort of results
um then perhaps uh we'd be in a stronger
position if
in future we wanted to try to persuade
the senate to
be cooperative and go along that would
that would strengthen the case
so i agree with you
based on that i can support this motion
i'm sorry did someone just say something
no i'm scanning for hands here
okay is there any further discussion
we would quick please state the motion
for the record and
do the roll call slowly so we can record
please
okay it's not recommended for
legislation missed the motion
yes
uh no nothing wrong
wilhelm yes
mckenna yes graham yes
right yes green
yes wall
yeah okay nine to one
okay uh representative graham could you
please
uh write your statement
and email a copy to me doug way
and to pam smiling please as soon as you
can
we'd like to get these written as soon
as we can i'd say within the next few
days please
yes madam chair thank you
okay moving along to house bill 1359
again that's one regarding employment as
a lobbyist
do we have a motion
remember folks you're not going to have
to fight this on the floor of the house
future legislation second
second is it okay representative graham
graham ii and rice
made the motion correct milk
good got it it's long distance isn't
working too well
is there a discussion on this motion
second call discussion on the motion
madam chair may i speak yes please thank
you
yeah i'm of two minds on this one i mean
i don't like the section
about the employment piece because i
still think that there's
i heard what representative frost said
i'm not sure if
i read it quite that way but okay um
so you know in terms of that i i have
some some question about
the specific bill i
you know i i sort of see some benefit to
maybe having at least a six month
waiting period
um but
by the same token i also wonder or i
i try to think about am i witnessing
um problems now um and and
i'm trying i'm racking my brain i'm
trying to think if i've seen
problems in other words that there's a
problem um that must be solved here
uh and i do hear i know the lot the
argument would be that it increases
public trust in the legislature
um i'm not sure how many people in the
public follow who's a lobbyist and who's
not
um so i i i think reluctantly i will go
along with a not
for future legislation
thank you oh janet speaking um
i i agree with you and i think it does
make sense to get a little space in
there but then i'm thinking
the term technically ends when the new
legislature is sworn in
however we usually finish the bulk of
our work
by june in an election year and then
the final election the general election
is until november there's a six month
gap right there
and then after everyone's sworn in
the real work for lobbyists doesn't
begin before
us at least until january
so there is a gap i guess if you want to
stretch it that way
i think it does make sense to have some
type of
grace period or whatever you want to
call it in there
some breathing room but
i agree with what the others have said
so i i will support this motion
does anyone else have anything else to
say more profound than what i had
did you have your hand up representative
frost before did i miss it no okay
okay a wheel shot
okay don't see anybody
i don't see any hands no okay um
wait wait uh representative wilhelm
representative okay
thank you madam chair i'm i'm gonna
oppose the motion
i i think there's
you know it's it's worth
continuing to work on this legislation i
know the details aren't aren't exactly
where we want them but
um you know i i find the entire
the process by which we study these
bills to be uh
complicated because you can't actually
you know if you study it
we're not actually refining it and then
putting something new forward
uh for you know the next
uh the next session to consider so i'm
gonna
i'm gonna oppose the motion uh in hopes
that it it
continues to be worked on next year
uh representative graham has his hand up
go ahead representative graham
uh thank you madam chair to paraphrase
what you said a couple of times already
no matter what we say or do in our
statements
and our recommendation any single member
of the next a session of the general
court can file a bill to do this
whether it be for two years six months
or
no action at all and i think that that
is
the entire problem with sending a bill
to interim study
is that we don't really solve anything
and this year has been even worse
because we haven't been able to actually
be to do any work on them
we usually resolve some of the problems
that we've been discussing
so i'm obviously going to support
the motion but i think that we all have
to understand that
interim study at least this term has
not worked the way that a lot of times
it does where we actually get
a lot more data to make a recommendation
with
thank you i understand where
representative wilhelm is coming from
and i think it
it's it's not an issue that's going to
go away i don't believe
i i do believe we can expect to see a
bill
at least one bill coming forward next
year
um i will simply say in my experience
i have only known one or two people in
all these years who have
gone into being lobbyists rather soon
after stepping out of the legislature
and
all the others have had at least a two
two and a half three year gap
in there who have become those who have
become lobbyists
but that's just from my experience and
again without any kind of law
defining that
i haven't seen a problem with those who
did go in a little bit sooner
as lobbyists but again i don't believe
it's an issue that will go away i will
support
the motion because i think there even
though
it's a concept that well it's a concept
that's going to be around for a while
um again the bill has been killed before
but it may pass one of these years i'm
going to support the
motion thank you
anyone
i else see anybody
i believe so okay representative kenny
can you repeat the motion please and
do the roll call not recommended for
further
legislation promotion representative lay
yes representative
yes what's it been
for us no
nothing going yes
but then wilhelm no
mckinney yes represent
graham yes
substantial right
yes represent
green yes
okay we've got two nose
percent of wall eight to two
yes
um representative rice can you get your
statement drafted fairly soon and get
copies to
myself representative lay and pam
smarling
yep we do thank you thank you
okay final bill 1669
requiring electronic filing of lobbyist
forms and statements
do we have a motion uh madam chairman
i i'll offer a motion yes
i would move uh that we not recommend
for legislation
i'm sorry who seconded that i'll second
that
representative rice seconded
representative lay made the motion
okay good enough do we have discussion
on this
may i speak to my motion yes please too
thank you
uh very simply i i just think that
yeah this probably would be more
effective in administrative rules
um and it would be good to check with
the secretary of state's office first to
find out where they even are on this
um there's no point in putting something
into statute that they're
hopefully actually going ahead to do i
know they are beginning to digitize more
and more of what they do at the
secretary of state's office
um and um i will trust what they
stated previously that this is something
they were planning to do anyways
so i think we can easily follow up and
find out whether it's happening or not
and if not
and there's a need for legislation then
we could go ahead and do something
thank you manager uh representative
graham has his handbook
i agree with um representative lay on
this
and the fact that the secretary of state
is
moving forward with um going digital
but remember that that all takes money
from us
and budget capital budget to continue to
go forward
and until we know exactly where we are
on that whole effort
i'd hate to put something in the law
with with
um hard deadlines or the rest
um before we do that and with
administrative rules they could get it
done this fall
if they're ready to go forward because
that committee is still meeting thank
you and i would add that we did hear
from the deputy
speakers excuse me deputy secretary of
state
and he did say that they were moving
forward to the best of their ability
uh coveted 19 has certainly interfered
with an awful lot of services
from every department an agency
and secretary of state's office i'm sure
has been inundated with all kinds of
extra work
but i trust that the work is going on i
i think it is worth
waiting to see and getting information
from them this year they can very well
report to the committee
without having a bill they can report
about the status
of their work so i i agree with the
motion that's been made that
we're better off holding off at this
point any further discussion
i am not seeing any hands okay they're
bringing on
come to court please read the motion and
do the roll call
okay not recommended for further
legislation it's promotion
representative lay yes
representative bernay yes
representative for us yes
nothing wrong yes
representative willem yes
mckinney yes graham yes
right yes
green yes
represent wall yeah
okay tendon
excellent okay and representatively i
trust you can get your statement written
fairly soon also
what if we put a deadline of say this
coming monday can you all get that done
by monday
for your statements yes
i can yeah i will okay otherwise we'll
be looking for you
is there any business to come before the
committee anymore
just like that represent the way
representative graham responds you sound
like some of my students
yes i'll do it
[Laughter]
i just want to thank everybody for being
so involved and for helping out during
this hard time that we're having you've
all been terrific
these two years and it's been a pleasure
working with you
um i just you're all good folks and you
have good ideas and even if we don't
always agree
still it is wonderful to work with you i
want to thank the staff again
i want to thank all the help we've
gotten throughout this whole process
pam you've been sterling and
we want to thank the others who have
been worth you i don't i didn't hear
that i didn't hear gents today or brad
but i presume you're somehow keeping in
touch with us
thank you staying muted
since you're the host is there anything
we should be doing now
besides signing off i think uh signing
off is all there is
left that was
everybody stay healthy please be safe be
healthy be happy
enjoy that little puppy and take good
care oh and enjoy little jason there
allison okay and the new and the newbie
uh for kids kendall
okay thank you all so much have a good
weekend you've been terrific
thanks thank you